this afternoon it was perfect weather
for some pine dining the much
anticipated event was held at the
temporary building on the site of the
mount charleston lodge cooking stations
were set up and tense and this weekend's
event featured chef james trees of
esther's kitchen tickets were sold for
75 bucks plus a 25 shuttle service all
the proceeds going to the als
association we asked trees how creating
an italian cuisine for esther's kitchen
translates to an event like pine dining
it definitely does not like we we uh
we we uh
we are cooking on the fly here this is a
whole different uh
cooking outdoors cooking
in a tent you know it's a whole
different thing than in a restaurant
where it's controlled so
it's all about maintaining you know
logistics and uh making sure that
everyone's having a good time that's the
most important thing to us
this weekend's events sold out so if
you're looking to go to their next event
act fast we have all the information on
our website 8newsnow.com